foreign
citizens of the reject Nation we are going to
talk about a whole bunch of DC news that just
dropped my goodness John how are you I'm great
how are you I'm excited doing well thank you for
asking we are on our way to go watch Black Adam
in just a few minutes early screening this news
dropped so once we come back from that movie I
gotta come back here and edit this so that's why
it's getting to you guys a little bit late we got
some things to discuss before we head out we got
news about Flash we got some Superman updates we
got a minor Wonder Woman update we got a little
James Gunn update and we also have Batman updates
there's so much to dive into and we're gonna have
to keep this really bite-sized because we're in a
rush right now to go watch this movie but here we
go let's kick it off with the one that I feel is
probably the most intriguing for a lot of people
it looks like finally after so long DC is actively
working on developing a follow-up for the Man of
Steel they are seeking screenwriters right now
all of this is being reported from The Hollywood
Reporter by the way they are developing an actual
follow-up and now we haven't seen Black Adam yet
but I'm sure all you guys have heard the rumors
about a certain someone that might appear in the
Black Adam post-credits scene seems like Dwayne
The Rock Johnson doesn't give two shits about
letting people know either I'm only gonna help
I guess to watch interviews with this guy I'm
like you're practically spelling it out man it's
like he's having fun with the audience it seems
very likely that Henry Cavill is going to make an
appearance at the end of Black Adam so with that
in mind it seems like we are finally getting the
thing that so many of us walk away disappointed
when we're like who's gonna show me Comic-Con it
didn't show up at Comic-Con I'm excited this is
what I've wanted for Henry Cavill for so long to
get a follow-up to his Man of Steel films now who
the writers might be that's all up for debate I
know at one point they were thinking maybe getting
Christopher McCory after working them on Fallout I
feel like he'd be a good writer but if Tom Cruise
is involved can Christopher McCrory really make
a good movie that's the key is it has to be a Tom
Cruise movie hey get Tom Cruise to Don the cape
you know no I feel like it's going to be Henry
Cavill I think Dwayne Johnson has successfully
been able to bring back Henry Cavill and now
they're finally going to proceed forward with it
and DC is saying that that was a great decision or
it might be a Black Adam versus Superman movie but
John how do you feel I'm excited I mean like as
a person who is kind of in the middle of the Man
of Steel debate seeing people who love it seeing
people who hate it being you know pretty fond
of the movie as of the whole DCU myself it feels
like one of those unique movie moments where this
easily could not have happened and I think a lot
of people are going to be so pleased that it seems
like it truly now is happening I can't imagine a
Time else wise where we would have such a Jeopardy
over a roll and then ultimately be paid off with
that actor being able to reprise and continue
on and then uh this was the other I'm going in
order of uh the thing I found most interesting
the least interesting we just want to mix it up
to keep your audience engaged I don't have a ton
of [__] around updates from Matt Reeves Batman
Universe we know that he's developing the Penguin
series that's already actively going he's working
on a follow-up for the Batman too now he's working
on more spin-offs right now it's not just TV show
spin-off some of them are going to be Standalone
movie spin-offs or perhaps you know the Batman
Universe so like Standalone but you know what I
mean and what's being reported currently in The
Hollywood Reporter is he's looking at characters
like scarecrow which is the one if you every time
someone asks me which Batman villain should
get a standalone film I always say scarecrow
for longest time I've had a pitch for what I
think the Scarecrow movie should beat Scarecrow
that excites me and especially with Matt Reeves
knowing how to abuse some horror into anything he
pretty much makes I feel like that would be great
looking at Clayface right now and then an oddball
Choice like Professor Pig so do it that's the one
everyone needs and this is one of the cool things
about a lot of our comic book characters is the
fact that you know we look at the big universe
dceu MCU but within our own characters there's a
universe that already exists so I love that they
are building out this bat universe and that
makes it feel easier to separate it as well
from the other parts of the DC Universe that are
clearly more connected via their films well yeah
and even if the DC EU itself is sort of still
forming its connective tissue I feel like it
makes a lot of sense to do Batman as its own sort
of side Universe the Rogues Gallery is so rich but
also it's the most steadily established superhero
franchise and the most steadily established DC
franchise so it makes a lot of sense to use that
as a bedrock and then shoot out and do more you
know Joker type stuff or Penguin series type
stuff or or things that Embrace stuff that's
been working but that they could easily capitalize
further on yeah I do find it interesting that this
time last year is when DC fandom took place and
they didn't do it this year and they decided to
give us a bunch of news in October anyway which I
think is great but next on the list we got got the
Flash 2 script is already written apparently yeah
man plead not guilty let's do this Ezra's gonna be
back that's kind of crazy that the Flash 2 strip
is already moving ahead because you know there's
all these talks coming out about us as we're going
to continue on in the DC Universe or not I mean
that's really up to I feel how people respond to
the movies so people love the movie and whatever
opinion you have about anything that happened
that was reported on whether you believe that's
real whether you believe that's fake it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter clearly it makes a lot
of money they're gonna make a sequel and they're
gonna put Ezra in there because there are people
who've come out and said that no no matter what
Ezra's out they have said that but the fact that
they already have a Flash 2 script already done
I feel like they would probably keep Ezra either
that or they've already recast yeah they already
know where they're going next next one here uh
the Wonder Woman three script mint coming soon
all right yeah that's not a big surprise I don't
think that's a big deal for that for a while yeah
I thought it was already where is it I thought by
now I'd be done yeah the last bit of news is James
gun is working on at least one more movie for uh
at least one new movie for the DC Universe I mean
The Suicide Squad is like one of the top like top
two for me when it comes to the DC Universe
films Peacemaker loved if you haven't seen
our reactions to It Go watch it love the hell
out of that show so good and already working on
season two and now James Gunn's gonna be working
on some new DC movie and it's it's a mystery film
like I'm not saying the movie's a mystery and
it's a mystery as to what this movie is going
to be yeah and I it could be a mystery bill for
all we know he did work on Scooby-Doo comics
who knows what it might be I mean he's talked
a lot about all kinds of characters he's want
to make even said at one point he was thinking
about doing a crypto movie but a league of Super
Pets already took care of that for him I don't
know I'm always you say James Gunn's working on
something and I'm immediately just excited you say
James producing something even if he's not writing
or directing I'm immediately interested in what
it's going to be because you could always feel
his fingerprints are going to be on it in some way
shape or form oh yeah that's why they need to get
specific about what it is there's like people will
be satisfied James guns going this is James Gunn's
name get it done so guys it looks like that we
are finally uh getting a lot of the ball going
here now are they gonna make Robert Pattinson's
Batman part of the you know connected Universe
because I know that's what really wants to aim for
right now and they're gonna need a Batman they're
gonna need a Batman that does connect because
they are going to want that Justice League I'm
not sure where they're going with this but I
think there are some pretty cool developments
here and of course to me the most exciting part
is finally they're moving forward with a real
follow-up I mean the article did state that the
JJ Abrams movie that he's supposed to be producing
is still in development too but I feel like
they're gonna can it I don't I just feel like
it's not gonna get me I feel like the odds are
good yeah like I don't know how much they're gonna
Embrace else worlds right now I feel like I don't
know as much as they've been quick to rush into
all sorts of stuff I feel like right now they're
trying to get consistent and then they will once
they've re-established Henry Cavill as Superman in
a satisfactory way that feels steady and assured
then we might get an alternate Superman but yeah I
could see it falling through either way man let's
get that Henry Cavill follow up let's go let's
get that Henry Cavill follow-up all right guys
subscribe click that Bell leave a like but we
don't want to leave you guys without doing it
Ricardo Martinez since this is a DC related
video I typed in on Google Ricardo DC character
and here's what we get on the prime Earth Here
Ricardo is a long time companion of Danny the
street which is a Doom Patrol character having
accompanied him since he was a cabana because
of this Ricardo has acted as an ally to the Doom
Patrol here are your abilities Ricardo Martinez
yeah you use a special magical jelly and your own
application technique Ricardo you are able to heal
people with massages that sounds like a beautiful
seductive gift and man who would have thought we
would have someone so sensual and jesus-like at
the same time at our patreon page Ricardo we are
lucky sons of ducks to have you man thank you
so much for being a Healer at the reject Nation